what we're going to do in this video is
discuss affirmative action and it can be
a sensitive topic so i encourage folks
to engage on the message boards but to
do so respectfully
so the first question is what is
affirmative action
so generally speaking you could view it
as efforts to
improve opportunities for
underrepresented
groups and often times it will be for
underrepresented
racial or ethnic groups or for women
to help us think through the types of
efforts that might be classified or that
might be associated with affirmative
action
we can set up a little bit of a spectrum
here at one
end of the spectrum you could have
outright quotas
these could be situations where say a
university admissions department says
we are going to say 10 of our class is
going to be from
this group or from that group in between
you could have
race or gender aware admissions where it
is a factor in admissions
race gender is a factor
is a factor and at this end of the
spectrum
there's outreach to groups to make sure
that people who could be qualified who
are from underrepresented groups
are applying so this would be outreach
now in popular language today
affirmative action
tends to refer to things more on this
end of the spectrum
and the phrase affirmative action first
comes into popular
usage during lyndon b johnson's
presidency
now as you can imagine this is a very
sensitive topic because on one hand
folks could say
yes it would be nice to give opportunity
for folks who historically have not had
opportunity or folks who are
historically underrepresented
but other people might say well
shouldn't we be a race-blind society
if you are factoring race for one group
well doesn't that hurt another group
and couldn't it cause reverse
discrimination and to appreciate the
legal
history here we can go back to 1978
where we have the case
regents of the university of california
v baki in the united states supreme
court
and this is a situation where becky is a
former soldier
and engineer who also happens to be
white who wants to go to medical school
he gets rejected by the university of
california at davis
and he claims that there was reverse
discrimination at play
because they had a quota system 16 out
of 100 seats at the medical school
were reserved for underrepresented
minorities
and the supreme court actually had
trouble deciding on this case
it was a very divided opinion and
eventually justice powell's opinion
became the opinion
that people paid attention to and it was
a little bit mixed
it said that outright quotas are
unconstitutional and that becky should
be
allowed admission and he was able to go
to university of california davis
medical school
but justice powell tried to thread the
needle by saying even though quotas
might be unconstitutional
it is okay to consider race as a factor
in admissions
especially if it's being used for the
educational benefit
of diversity of the community in 1996
the voters of california
actually voted directly on this issue
and they passed
the california civil rights initiative
more commonly known as proposition
209 and this proposition made it illegal
to consider race sex or ethnicity when
it came to
government jobs or admissions in state
schools
it has been challenged by proponents of
affirmative action many times
but all of those challenges have been
unsuccessful to date
these issues surface again in the
supreme court in 2003
when we get to the gruter vs bollinger
case
this case has some parallels to the
backy case
in this case gruter is a white applicant
to the university of michigan law school
who claims that she was denied admission
because the law school was giving
racial preference which was causing
essentially reverse discrimination
the supreme court rules against gruter
but it's really interesting to read
the majority opinion written by sandra
day o'connor
and the dissenting opinion from clarence
thomas because it gives us some texture
into the nuances of these decisions here
is an excerpt from
sandra day o'connor's majority opinion
we last addressed the use of race in
public higher education over 25 years
ago
in the landmark bakke case we reviewed a
racial set-aside program that reserves
16 out of 100 seats in a medical school
class
for members of certain minority groups
since this court's splintered decision
in backe
justice powell's opinion announcing the
judgment of the court has served as the
touchstone
for constitutional analysis of race
conscious admissions policies
and then she goes on to list the
situations that justice powell said were
not okay
to justify race as a factor in
admissions
justice powell rejected an interest in
reducing the historic
deficit of traditionally disfavored
minorities in medical schools
and in the medical profession as an
unlawful
interest in racial balancing so
according to justice powell in the bakke
case
you can't justify race conscious
admissions to try to fix
historic deficits sandra day o'connor
goes on to write
justice powell in the backy case
rejected an
interest in remedying societal
discrimination because such measures
would risk placing unnecessary burdens
on innocent third parties
who bear no responsibility for whatever
harm the beneficiaries of the special
admissions program
are thought to have suffered so you also
can't have race conscious admissions if
the goal is to remedy
current societal discrimination because
if you're benefiting someone
you're also putting the burden on people
who might have nothing to do with that
societal discrimination and then she
goes on to write that in the backy case
justice powell approved the university's
use and here we're talking about the
university of california's use
of race to further only one interest the
attainment
of a diverse student body and now in
this part of the excerpt she shifts to
talking about
the case at hand in gruder vs bollinger
where we're talking about admissions to
the university of michigan law school
as part of its goal of assembling a
class that is both
exceptionally academically qualified and
broadly diverse
the law school seeks to enroll a
critical mass of minority students
the law school's concept of critical
mass is defined by reference to the
educational benefits that diversity is
designed to produce
these benefits are substantial as the
district court emphasized
the law school's admissions policy
promotes cross-racial understanding
helps to break down racial stereotypes
and enables
students to better understand persons of
different races
we the majority in the supreme court
agree that in the context of its
individualized inquiry into the possible
diversity contributions of
all applicants the law school's race
conscious admissions program
does not unduly harm non-minority
applicants
in summary the equal protection clause
of the 14th amendment
does not prohibit the law school's
narrowly tailored use
of race and admissions decisions to
further a compelling interest
in obtaining the educational benefits
that flow from a diverse
student body so in this situation the
majority opinion that's penned by
justice o'connor is clarifying
powell's statement in vacky saying that
diversity is a legitimate
educational benefit that universities
can
optimize around as long as race is one
of many factors
in the admissions process now on the
other hand you have the dissenting
opinion from
justice clarence thomas here's an
excerpt he wrote
i believe blacks can achieve in every
avenue of american life without the
meddling of university administrators
because i wish to see all students
succeed whatever their color
i share in some respect the sympathies
of those who sponsor the type of
discrimination advanced
by the university of michigan law school
the constitution does not
however tolerate institutional devotion
to the status quo and admissions
policies
when such devotion ripens into racial
discrimination
so he's calling the university of
michigan law school's admissions
policies
outright discrimination he's saying that
look even though it might be the status
quo
it's essentially what a lot of
universities have been doing since baki
it's not okay because it has ripened
into racial discrimination
the majority he's talking about the
majority of the supreme court upholds
the law school's racial discrimination
not by interpreting the people's
constitution so the u.s constitution
but by responding to a fattish slogan of
the cognoscenti
so here he's making reference to this
idea of diversity which he's calling a
fattish slogan of the cognoscenti
cognoscenti would be people who are in
the know or who people who think they're
in the know
nevertheless i concur in part in the
court's opinion
i agree with the court's holding that
racial discrimination and higher
education admissions
will be illegal in 25 years and here
he's making reference that in sandra day
o'connor's opinion
she did say that in 25 years it might
not be
okay to have race conscious admissions i
respectfully dissent from the remainder
of the court's opinion and the judgment
however
because i believe that the law school's
current use of race
violates the equal protection clause and
that the constitution
means the same thing today as it will in
300 months
so here he's saying look if the majority
thinks that it's right now okay to have
race conscious admissions but it's not
okay in
25 years well what's going to change
about the constitution if it's going to
be unconstitutional
in 25 years it should be
unconstitutional today
finally he goes on to say the
constitution abhors classifications
based on race
not only because those classifications
can harm favored races
or are based on illegitimate motives but
also because
every time the government places
citizens on racial registers
and makes race relevant to the provision
of burdens or benefits
it demeans us all i encourage you to
think about it
are you more on the side of justice
powell or sandra day o'connor where
race is a legitimate factor in
admissions especially if it's in service
to diversity which is considered
a benefit for an educational community
or are you more on the side of justice
thomas and proposition 209 in california
saying that look we need to be racially
blind the 14th amendment
the equal protection clause of the 14th
amendment
says that we should be a racially blind
country and that every time we try to
involve race
it might do more harm than good you
decide